people love superheroes
they swooped out of the sky to save the
day people love that cozy feeling they
simply ask given
my deepest condolences to Robyn's family
she just stepped in the middle of the
street you know she was a half step off
the [ __ ] car down come on Hughie just
don't get upset Supes lose hundreds of
people each year it's a collateral
damage
it's [ __ ] diabolical they're all over
all of them yeah pardon my french [ __ ]
those [ __ ] I've got the boys together
now Jonas
yeah it's a date what spank the bastard
Robin you've suicide to go after the
Supes we can use help stuffing now
excuse me I'm sorry are you okay I'm
fine I'm just having a bad day it's a
work thing
I'm supposed to be this hero Idol symbol
but I don't know what the hell I'm doing
she could help us she's a super just
arrested them you're all about her
just remember will your friends enemies
ha
they just declared war
you can't do this you don't have the
fight you never have
do it
this kid is full surprises
well well well if you know what it looks
like I thought we had an understanding
and when you're trying to be tough but
or superheroes
who are you
you